crowds and security rushed to the
entrance of Janine refugee camp where
just over a week ago the Israeli Army
had forced its way in
you are the icon of resistance in the
face of Israeli aggression
surrounded by guards Palestinian
president Mahmoud Abbas had a unifying
message
whoever wants to attack us we won't
accept any attack from anyone and we
will stay standing and patient let
Palestine be free of this aggressive
occupation let us get rid of it and we
say move away from our homeland this is
the first time Palestinian president in
and people have come out in the
blistering heat to welcome him so many
people we've spoken to say they now need
help to rebuild their lives
president Abbas and the Palestinian
Authority have been under pressure his
popularity has plummeted many
Palestinians are angry with its security
coordination with Israel and arrests of
fighters from time to time also his lack
of presence in the northern occupied
West Bank which critics say made way for
the rise of armed groups inside the
camps
come on the biggest factions here are
the Janine Battalion which is the
Islamic Jihad armed group and the Alexa
Matas Brigade which is the fatah armed
group
they started gaining momentum in 2021
others include the Lions and Annapolis
and now there are more groups emerging
in tokorum and Jericho which poses even
more challenges for Abbas
he's worried Israel will quit their
support for the authority especially
because inside the Israeli government
some ministers are demanding the
Palestinian Authority is pushed towards
collapse he's also trying to convince
the Americans that he still exists and
is active and present
but so many people inside the Janine
Camp are calling on the Palestinian
Authority to improve their lives
when the Israeli Army launches assault
Rima Abu al-hajair says she locked
herself four children and her baby in
this room while listening to the
explosions outside
my 14 year old daughter freaked out got
very scared the class fell on our heads
afterwards the Army came inside for us
the dogs entered brown and black and
they took my cousin away
if she had any message for president
Abbas
the most important thing is to rebuild
the infrastructure in the camp and the
houses that were demolished
after years in power people here are
asking if the policy and Authority is
still effective president Abbas came
with warm words and promises but many
here say it's time to deliver on those
promises